[Music]
welcome back everyone this is going to
be my loki episode 1 video we are
burdened with glorious episodes finally
so i'm doing videos for
all the episodes in season one be sure
to subscribe to get everything
we're doing a giveaway for disney plus
memberships all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and let me know what
your favorite easter egg from the
episode was
careful for spoilers if you have not
seen the episode yet we'll be talking
about everything and i'll just start at
the beginning of the episode
and number these as we go along and talk
about easter eggs and wtf moments
they set up a lot of really big stuff
but it is the first episode so there's a
lot of table setting and explaining
what's going on
but starting at the beginning the title
of the episode is glorious purpose
a reference to his catchphrase from the
first avengers movie which he repeats
during the episode
he repeats a lot of his dialogue in his
big speeches from the avengers movies
but it's also a reference to loki
finding a new glorious purpose at the
end of the episode a new mission given
to him by mobius
new opportunity i can't give you
salvation but maybe i can give you
something better
owen wilson was fantastic during the
episode as mobius
i'll explain his character in a second
too but he also calls loki on a lot of
his bull crap
like what is your glorious purpose what
would happen if you became king of
midgard king of earth
would you become king of space next what
would you do if you're a king of space
and it's like loki doesn't have an
answer for that like he's not thought it
through
that much but the episode starts in the
same avengers and game time travel scene
to 2012 with them redoing the elevator
scene of them carting loki off
they did change this a little bit they
added some footage and they got rid of
some stuff just kind of speed things
along like they zoom in on his face as
he's waving goodbye to the hulk as they
make him take the stairs
but they speed run to the part where
loki gets his hands on the tesseract so
they can just get to the moment where he
portals away and winds up in the gobi
desert
it is a very iron man one inspired scene
they have that funny moment with the
locals where he sort of rushes to sort
of collect himself and stand on the rock
like he's getting ready to perform for
them and he gives him the same
loki i am burdened with glorious purpose
speech that he gave at the beginning of
the first avengers movie
they also give him his own custom
version of the marvel intro logo just
like they did on wandavision and falcon
and winter soldier it wasn't quite as
crazy on falcon and winter soldiers was
on one division
the loki version just changes the logo
to loki green
but just as the locals are giving him
the business like what are you who are
you what are you doing here
the time variance authority hunters and
the minutemen portal in so that's what
they're calling these hunters here
they're calling them the minutemen
most of the naming scheme of the tva is
based on
puns for time travel then hunter b15
wumi masaku's character comes in she's
sort of one of the main characters in
the series even though
all these characters are part of the tva
she's like one of the main hunters
i made the night court reference in a
previous video she's kind of like raw's
from night court the bailiff who will
just wreck you if you look at them the
wrong way
because the tva is kind of like night
court for mcu time travel villains
she starts talking about the rate of
change in the timeline the slope the
increase
so during the episode when they talk
about branch timelines hitting redline
what that means is that it approaches a
certain limit when it eventually becomes
a fully
alternate reality so they want to stop
it from hitting redline
and clip the branch so to speak which is
what those special devices are that they
use here so it basically
resets this part of the timeline this
localized area as if it never happened
for these people
but you also get a good sense for some
of their other core technology too like
they have those stun batons
but they also have what they call the
time twisters which basically
alter the flow of time for individual
people so loki just winds up there
feeling the sting as if it's like a
continuous punch
that just goes on for a minute it's
actually a little bit sinister you can
use that to torture someone something
fierce
and there are a lot of sinister
overtones with the whole idea of the tva
and the timekeepers that i'll talk about
as we go through the rest of the episode
very clearly foreshadowing them is some
of the bigger antagonists in the series
there are obviously some big twists that
they foreshadowed during the episode too
like the people you think are the
villains
probably aren't the real villains when
he says he's had a very long day he's
referring to his failed invasion of
earth during the first avengers movie
with thanos shitauri forces
and says that he's had his fill of
idiots and armored suits referencing the
avengers then she muzzles him with that
control collar which is very similar to
the control collar that thor put on him
preventing him from using his powers and
binding him to that special time twister
then they set the reset device and take
loki back to the time keeper's citadel
at the end
of time the technical term for it in the
comics is the citadel at the end of time
because it was created literally at the
end of the timeline before the heat
death of this version of the universe
but within the mcu the way they talk
about this place this whole facility
it sort of exists in its own little
pocket dimension outside the normal flow
of space-time so it's protected from
things like
thanos snapping the infinity gauntlet so
none of these people in this place got
snapped by thanos
but you can see how some of these other
moments early on are meant to answer
some of the biggest questions like how
come
we've never heard about you till now
loki even asked that question to mobius
and he says well because you've never
had to
which is kind of a meta answer too to
the audience was because we never really
needed to tell a time travel story
until after avengers end game in this
big multiverse overarching story of
marvel phase 4 that we're in the middle
of right now
but within the context of the story the
reason why nobody really talks about the
tva
in the avengers movies because they
don't know about them is because they've
been using the time
reset devices every time something has
happened implying that there have been
times when things have happened
but i love their design language for the
tv8 it's got this very tactile
1970s sci-fi vibe to it very british
seeming too like they're mixing a lot of
classic sci-fi series like the
hitchhiker's guide meets doctor who
meets the citadel of rix from rick and
morty and if you are a big rick and
morty fan the show runner michael
waldron actually came from rick and
morty season 3 to do this show
and he also wrote doctor strange 2
multiverse of madness
the loki series is their first legit
multiverse series in the marvel
cinematic universe so it will have some
crossover elements that help set up
doctor strange 2 the same way that
wandavision did
and i will talk about the whole
multiversal war that they referenced
which is obviously a big secret wars
lead up
they tease a ton of stuff there is a lot
of setup for many
many different things so don't be
surprised if you re-watch the episode a
couple times and you keep finding new
things and new easter eggs
but the whole idea of the citadel of
ricks on rick and morty is funny because
it was actually based on marvel's
council of reeds in the comics
they're a multiverse team of reed
richards from alternate universes who
team up to create a think tank
so loki doing rick and morty is kind of
like them completing the circle of
references
a marvel project referencing something
else that itself
was referencing marvel but as she takes
loki into book him we see a variant
scroll being booked
then just another human douchebag red
shirt that they're using for comedy
during the episode as part of loki's
journey
who claims his father is super rich and
on the board of goldman sachs
they also use this scene to demonstrate
how the other time travel tech works
preventing loki the other prisoners from
escaping
like i said just kind of meant to set up
some of the jokes at the end of the
episode when he starts using the
technology against them
they also use this to set up the joke
with a desk clerk about the infinity
stones and the tesseract later in the
episode
with his desk drawer full of all kinds
of versions of infinity stones from
different universes
like infinity stone that sounds stupid
that's marvel basically making fun of
themselves too
for using the infinity stones as such
big plot devices
for the entire 10-year run of the
infinity saga movies
bit of a meta reference for marvel phase
42 kind of like saying that
infinity stones will not be a thing
during marvel phase four
then she introduces loki to the
processing queue he goes on about how
amazing his fine asgardian leather
costume is
didn't know he was such a closed horse
it vaporizes it right off his body you
get that funny scene with him being
naked
then they have this very funny
complicated system of floor drops where
they drop him a couple levels through
each different room
sticking him automatically in a prison
jumpsuit as he has to verify
every single word that he's ever uttered
he had that funny scene with a cat which
is probably not a cat
as a lot of you have probably guessed a
cat is never just a cat in the mcu now
it's probably a florkin then they
promptly dump him down another level and
make him verify that he was born as an
organic being
and he does have a soul they use it for
a couple of jokes too like loki wonders
for a second like wait a minute what if
i were a robot and i didn't know it
like for just a hot second he does kind
of wonder wait a minute am i really a
person
but what they're referencing there
though are beings like vision and
ultron living machines that technically
don't have souls although if you are a
big star trek the next generation fan
there was a very notable episode that
dealt with this exact idea the whole
idea that data
did not have a soul and by the end the
court decided that it was up to data to
decide for himself
whether or not he had a soul they take
that photograph of his temporal aura
sort of to set up some of the later
twists in the episode they sort of use
those to track the different variants so
like
you leave your aura your temporal aura
on things that you touch when you travel
around the multiverse it's like a more
complex version
of a time travel fingerprint as they
travel into the queue you see a bunch of
posters we see
miss minutes if her voice sounded
familiar that's because tara strong
is the voice of miss minutes most of the
posters all the flair all over the
building in the different parts of the
episode are all references to time
travel
like this one reads behave don't get
your clock cleaned and when they say
clean they mean scrubbed as in
deleted which we see happen within a
couple minutes of this they also play a
lot of time travel jokes too
like miss minutes repeats the exact
thing that loki said as if they knew
that he was going to say it
but then as he's going through the queue
this minutes basically gives him the
tutorial on the tva the history of the
tva
and it says the tva was created because
of a vast
multiversal war that's a reference to
marvel's
secret wars happening in the future of
the mcu
i'll probably do a separate video about
this because we've all been talking
about secret wars even the russo
brothers have been talking about doing a
version of secret wars in the avengers
movies
with all these alternate timelines fully
alternate realities battling each other
for supremacy like a bunch of variant
universes battling each other until the
time keepers emerged and created what
they call the single
sacred timeline for the entire
multiverse so the way they're canonizing
time travel in the mcu timelines
is that there's one timeline that
encompasses the entire
multiverse all these alternate universes
and when a new branch timeline is
created they treat it like a fully
alternate reality
and those happen through nexus points
big major events that alter the flow of
time
but during this part of the episode and
then later several times
in the episode loki has this big speech
there are other big speeches about the
nature of free will
people not really having free will
because the time keepers dictate
everything that's supposed to happen
everyone's destinies it's meant to give
off a very sinister vibe
because when mobius is calling loki out
for his avengers speech
giving to all those people from the
first avengers movie about them craving
to be subjugated
free will being a bad thing it's the
same idea with the time keepers in the
tva so i feel like that's a big
foreshadowing moment that the time
keepers themselves are going to wind up
being
bigger antagonists in the series than
this other alternate loki that they're
trying to hunt down
you also notice during some of these
animations like when he's describing
variants you notice the background looks
exactly like the landscape on titan from
avengers infinity war
but a lot of you will probably remember
one division when they mentioned nexus
event
because nexus was a big concept they
introduced on one division
that was meant to be an easter egg for
scarlet witch as a nexus being
in the mcu so nexus beings are rare
individual entities
with the ability to affect probability
in thus the future
thereby altering the flow of the
universal time stream or the sacred
timeline as they call it on the loki
series
these beings each referred to as a nexus
like scarlet witch act as the keystones
of the multiverse and are crucial to its
ultimate coherence in stability
so these beings nexus beings are
vigilantly watched over by the cosmic
forces like the time variance authority
in the time keepers to be aware of any
temporal changes
so for instance loki is not a nexus
being but because he had the infinity
stone he was able to create a big enough
change that it created these branch
timelines
what they're saying is that scarlet
witch as a nexus being doesn't need an
infinity stone to do that she could
change the future on this scale
without that that'll sort of play into
the idea of doctor strange 2 multiverse
of madness
listen to your connection point to that
movie from the loki series
but they also give you the tva's
official slogan for all time
always as written by what they're
calling the narrative commission
the funny meta reference here the
narrative being a reference to the story
of the mcu like
for instance kevin feige is the head of
the narrative commission
of marvel studios because he says what
the story is going to be
but then them melting this douchebag is
just meant to be a call back to thor
ragnarok and that funny moment where
thor
freaked out watching the grandmaster
melt his underling after he
himself going through a similar type of
processing queue then they play the loki
title screen
and obviously the shifting style of the
letters of his name are meant to be
references to all the alternate versions
of loki that we'll see during the series
then we get into the storyline with this
alternate loki that's going around
killing tva hunters in 1549 france
mobius investigating the scene of one of
these crimes
so my early theory here just based on
all the evidence they've provided in all
the trailer footage that we've seen
is is probably lady loki the female
version of loki that they're hunting
down but the way they explain it this
other loki had apparently set a trap for
the tva they sort of pay this off at the
end of the episode too like purposefully
setting a trap for them
so that she could steal this special
time reset device
i believe this stained glass window
behind mobius as he's talking about the
crime here is meant to be joan of arc
because we're in france in a church
and it's meant to foreshadow the lady
loki twist being responsible for all
this
like they're using joan of arc's story
as a metaphor for the story of lady loki
if you're not a big history buff joan of
arc was burned at the stake for heresy
against the church
the tva is kind of like a timed church
so to speak they call it the sacred
timeline
they erase people burn them kind of so
to speak it kind of looks like they're
being burned or vaporized here
when they're deemed variants or heretics
against the main timeline
so it's like lady loki on the loki
series is joan of arc
metaphorically which also plays into the
idea that she is not the real villain
here even though they're kind of
portraying her that way at the beginning
of the series
like i said a lot of big twists that
they're setting up here the showrunner
also clarified the stained glass window
depiction of the devil here
and the director also backed this up
that at no point did they ever
discuss mephisto on the series so this
depiction of the devil is not meant to
be mephisto
although they do make a nightmare
reference later in the episode too
nightmare and mephisto completely
different characters we find out that
this alternate loki possibly lady loki
gave this little kid in the church the
kablooey gum
the devil bearing gifts reference
blueberry but then just as they're about
to reset this part of the timeline
another agent steps through and hands
him the file on this version of loki
notice all the stuff on his file here
too it also correctly identifies his
race as a frost giant even though he was
born a runt
his birthplace is yodenheim home of the
frost giants and notice
the sector reads up to 2099 that's a
reference to marvel's 2099 comic book
story universe like spider-man 2099 who
was played by oscar isaac during
spider-man into the spider-verse
in big coincidence oscar isaac is also
playing the live-action version of moon
knight in the moon knight disney plus
series
the whole thing with loki's gender being
fluid is just a reference to lady loki
like i said all this pointing to lady
loki easter eggs
but then we meet gugu and badumrah's
judge rents lair character she's based
on ravana renslayer from the comics
long time love interest of king the
conquer she said that the loki series is
meant to be something of an origin story
for her
as well so she expects to come back in
other marvel projects
if we see more kang the conquer easter
eggs from her storyline i'll point them
out
for the most part i believe that she's
supposed to be a good character there's
a lot of foreshadowing with her
character in this big tva
time keepers reveal as well but the
three faces above her aren't so much
meant to be a reference to king the
conqueror as they are meant to be the
faces of the three time keepers from the
comics but the middle face above her
does look similar to
one of kang's faces she identifies this
loki variant as number
l1130 charged with sequence violation
720 89. i feel like the date is probably
somebody's birthday but i don't know
whose
we get that funny speech from loki
trying to talk his way out of the
situation trying to throw the avengers
under the bus
oh well the only reason i'm here that i
have the tesseract is because they time
traveled in the first place
believe me i would know the stench of
two tony stark's cologne
which itself is another reference to the
axe body spray joke from avengers end
game like what are you wearing there is
that axe body spray
then they sort of answer the question of
why the avengers weren't hauled in
because the avengers according to the
timekeepers wishes
did what they were supposed to do they
were supposed to time travel
then as loki sort of takes her to task
on all this like how do you know that
this is the time keeper's will like what
are you doing here
the way she talks about it ravana she's
never actually met the time keeper so i
think it's going to be one of those
revelations where it's like have you met
the timekeepers have you met the
timekeepers no have you
no i haven't met them either how does
anyone know that this is really what
their will
is to make a wizard of oz reference who
is behind the curtain
but then they set him up for that big
joke of him trying to use his powers to
escape
but the control collar prevents him from
using them they also explain that
there's a wide area nullifier that just
covers the entire area of the tva's time
citadel that prevents people from using
any kind of magic
then mobius steps in to try and speak
for him and get him on his case
but when he says i thought there was no
magic here that's meant to be a callback
to the first thor movie when thor was
explaining
advanced asgardian technology like the
bifrost to jane foster
they made the whole joke about magic
being just advanced science that you
don't understand yet
although technically there is magic and
mystical energy in the mcu
but the doctor strange movie sort of
explained it using scientific principles
but one of the big easter eggs here in
the background you see the building
reads
t282 here that's a reference to thor
issue 282
thor vs tempus who was a time travel
minion of king of the conkers
also the tva itself is a concept debuted
in the thor comics but it's mostly been
used in thor stories and in fantastic
four stories
mobius the character that owen wilson is
playing actually debuted in the
fantastic four comic book
but the way they wrote him on the series
is to be sort of like the deckard
character in blade runner like you think
about the blade runner reference to all
the different replicants
it's meant to be the same concept with
this version of loki that we're
following
as he goes around and learns about these
alternate loki's he in turn
learns more about himself and gains more
self acceptance that's sort of what that
final scene with him and mobius is at
the end of the series where he talks
about
not really liking hurting people i don't
like to hurt people i do this because i
have to and he sort of recalibrates his
whole concept of his glorious purpose
he makes the joke about burning the
place of the ground and mobius actually
makes a reference to nightmare
saying that that's a whole other
department he's making a reference to
the nightmare dimension which is the
place where the being
nightmare from the comics rules make all
the one division nightmare
jokes originally he was actually
supposed to be the main villain of
doctor strange 2 when scott derrickson
was still directing
the new main villain of multiverse of
madness will be different though
but in the elevator you notice all the
buttons go to all the different floors
it's meant to be as confusing as
possible like one of them is a miss
minutes button that probably takes you
to the place where her core operating
system resides
later in the credits too in the elevator
one of the readings says access denied
which would probably be part of the big
reveal about what's really going on like
big wizard of oz reference what is
behind the curtain
what are we not supposed to see here
when loki calls the time keepers space
lizards that's because they kind of look
reptilian in the comics
then mobius takes him into their time
theater where he shows him the highlight
reel of his greatest moments so far
and his future later in the episode
although loki kind of spins that out for
himself like he just continues watching
the reel
he makes a reference to loki only
trusting himself that's also
foreshadowing for
loki's interactions with these other
loki variants as they appear in episodes
you may have actually spotted the josta
soda reference here it might sound like
a marvel reference like joe costa
but josta was actually a pepsi energy
drink it was the very first energy drink
that they tried to market in the united
states so just meant to be a reference
that because the time variance authority
has
ultimate control of time travel in the
timeline they can have any kind of thing
that they want
we watch the avengers take him down we
watch him kill coulson again
we actually find out that loki was
really db cooper they sort of clarify
the scene from all the trailers
so the way they explained this is
because loki back in the 1970s about 50
years ago
this is not an alternate timeline it's
the real main version of loki
lost to bet to thor so they're not
really clear about what the bet was
about
but they say basically db cooper's heist
which is a real world thing from the
early 1970s
is what loki had to do because he lost
the bed then he starts hitting him with
the other loki's future the original
loki's future
showing him about how he was responsible
for the death of his mother frigga
and that's really when it starts to hit
him and the whole reason why mobius
keeps asking him if he enjoys killing
people if he enjoys hurting people
is just because he wants to get him to
the point in his arc where he's honest
with himself about
who he really is and why he's doing all
these things then his woomy musaku's
hunter interrupts telling mobius they
lost another person loki uses it an
opportunity to escape
but as he ducks into the desk clerk's
office here they play it for that other
big reveal of the infinity stones
we find out that they are lousy with
extra infinity stones
and there's obviously a lot of other
easter eggs inside this drawer that i'll
talk about in a second
but just to explain the reason why the
infinity stones are useless
normally in the comics infinity stones
only work in the universe
that they came from and because the tva
exists in its own little pocket
dimension
it's technically an alternate reality no
infinity stones from other realities
would work there
so as he says they use them as
paperweights but some of these easter
eggs i couldn't quite pick out because
the text is too small a little too
blurry but like you have a poker chip
here that could be a poker chip from the
first iron man film
there's a french medal of honor i'm not
sure whose historical picture this is
but it feels like it's meant to be
someone incredibly famous
there's an old spanish dagger that seems
like it belonged to a conquistador
there's a circular coil of wires that
seems like it's a reference to an iron
man arc reactor but then his hunter b15
chases him back down almost winds up
vaporizing him
he rewinds himself back to the time
theater and uses the extra
time to watch the rest of his original
timeline play out
but then we see the events of thor
ragnarok he watches as his father
accepts him truly as his son like the
thing that he always wanted
then he watches as thanos kills himself
and it just utterly shocked silent
by it it reminded me that scene from
christmas vacation where chevy chase is
watching his home movies in the attic
just crying his eyes out
and you notice that as the timeline ends
after he dies
the tape reads loki 616 a reference to
the marvel 616
universe but technically in the past
marvel has used a different universe
designation for the mcu
but you get the idea 616 was meant to
represent the main loki's timeline
and finally mobius comes back in after
he sort of hits rock bottom
and explains what the mission is we need
you because
the other person that's killing all
these men is a version of you we're
hunting
loki and they transitioned to oklahoma
in 1858 with the same team from france
earlier it's the same hunter who was
talking about the loki that was stabbing
people
they find some technology from the year
3000 that this alternate loki possibly
lady loki has left as a trap
but they think that someone just came to
steal oil and get rich
the twist being that lady loki used the
oil to burn them down
and steal their time reset device she's
going around laying traps for them
stealing their devices preventing them
from closing down these alternate
timelines
but then there's this enormous montage
of a bunch of different easter eggs and
references
during the end credits it's all
reference to mobius case files
for instance the apocalyptic event
reports are just the standard reports
about the crazy things that happen the
killings that they're going around
investigating but you also notice that
the number nine keeps showing up across
the files repeatedly like the cabinets
as well so that's all probably connected
to the big reveal of this alternate loki
lady loki possibly
it's being played by this actress here
who's actually with tom hiddleston at
the london premiere
i'll talk more about her when we finally
actually get to see her on screen but
i'm expecting it to be kind of an agatha
harkness kind of reveal where you don't
fully learn what's really going on with
her till later in the series
but everyone let me know in the comments
what was your favorite moment from the
episode and if there are any big easter
eggs that you spotted that i didn't
mention in the video just write them
below in the comments
i'll do an episode 2 trailer video next
and there's a couple bonus videos that i
plan i'll do a video about the big
secret wars teaser that they're setting
up in doctor strange 2 multiverse of
madness connections
and i'll name a giveaway winner when i
post that next video while you wait for
everything everyone click here for all
my loki videos and click here for my
brand new thor 4 love and thunder first
look teaser video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you